losing a lot of gangster names we lost
one of the biggest gangsters in the
whole world just recently
goddamn crocodile hunter is gone
children he's gone
that's my [__] y'all that [__]
was the [__]
crocodile hunter was this [__] he wasn't
scared of [__] if you think he ain't
gangsta go to your neighbor house and
jump on they rottweilers and see how
that worked out for you
that white boy was a [__] cause he
wasn't mean or nasty or nothing
he was friendly and informational
my mother would be hunting crocodiles oh
that's a beauty right there mate
all right i've got her in my sights now
wait for it
wait for it what
[Applause]
she tried to do the bloody death roll on
me did you say you're trying to rule
[__] you gonna kill that [__]
and just show you how haters be on you
this [__] didn't get killed by
crocodile
he got killed by a punk bitch-ass
stingray ain't that some [__]
he wasn't even a stingray hunter you
know crocodile was talking [__] the next
day just i knew something bad was gonna
happen to him [__] i knew it
nah he wrassle my uncle down on national
tv [__] made a belt and some shoes out
of me
you know but again the crocodile hunter
i give him i give him a lot of love a
lot of credit but you know people go
he's such a loss to the nature community
you know
he taught us so much about nature
and i got mad when i heard this lady on
tv saying that he taught us a lot about
nature and it was like
no he didn't really teach a lot about
nature if you want to learn about nature
you watch discovery channel or one of
these
you know nature programs where they have
a guy on safari
and he's studying from afar crocodile
hunter and all come on every episode
hey all you doing look over there
right there it's a tiger and tiger
weighs 800 pounds and it could kill a
man in 10 seconds
i'm gonna touch it
[Applause]
he's angry he's hot he's angry
next episode ah that's a king cobra the
most venomous snorkeling all the planet
one boy now i'm dead i'm gonna pick it
up
he's angry
if he really wanted people to think he
was out there man america we should have
borrowed him
and sent him to iraq with no gun just a
camera crew
you imagine how bad that would have
freaked out the enemy you know you're
freaking a soldier working for al qaeda
and you're out there you know
[Music]
and he's walking towards him wearing
shorts
[Applause]
an iraqi soldier one of the most
dangerous creatures in all the planet
one push of a button and i'm gone
i'm gonna poke him with a stick
[Applause]
i love the crocodile hunter that was my
one of my favorite shows man
guy you know because how can you not
like watching a show
where a guy's hunting a crocodile you
know you can't get a more fun show than
that you know
and uh but anyways and then he died and
it was sad
and people were following me and i was
sad about it and everything but some
people found me were shocked
you know they were like man did you hear
who died i'm like who
the crocodile hunter
seems impossible
but he died of all people
he was only 44 years old
which i think is a ripe old age for a
crocodile hunter you know
you think this guy didn't have a little
hard time getting life insurance you
know what i mean
guys like uh i'm looking at your
occupation here i don't know if there's
a joke or whatever but
says here you're a crocodile hunter
is that you know see i'm just [__]
losing people
i am i just look at tv and nothing makes
sense to me i'm sick of them telling me
[__] is shocking
that it's completely obvious crocodile
hunter dies
can you [__] yes yes i can totally
believe it's why i watch the show
i watched it every week because i knew
eventually he was going to [__] die
and i wanted i wanted to see it
right
oh i like that uh that dog the bounty
hunter video
or the uh the phone message he left you
know people like can you believe he left
he left that racist message it's like
dude look at him
look at him some redneck with a mullet
down to his ass he drives a pickup
he's got the gloves with the fingers cut
off yeah who would have thought he had a
couple of [__] up ideas rolling around
in his head you know
dude you know what would have been
shocking if he could play the cello
that would have been shot right
and then you'd be sitting there like my
goddamn look at doc
here it is i thought he was some racist
on his way to his steak and shake and
he's busting out a little beethoven god
damn i owe this guy an apology you know
god i'd love to see his ipod i can't
imagine the eclectic mix of music
this is how much time i spend alone on
the road man i actually spent so much
time
alone on the road actually like
contemplated milk to the point i can't
even [__] drink it anymore
sitting there drinking like man stuff is
great tastes awesome you know then i
started thinking it comes out of the
carton
and i just did the police work it comes
out of a cow and i'm like i am [__]
suckling for another species
we have such a crazy relationship with
cows
do you ever think about that no you can
nurse from it you can eat it
right you can tip it over when it's
sleeping but if you [__] it you're going
to jail
but there's one tv show that i love so
very much because it is so in the minds
of every single person
even the nice young lady in the front
seat my apologies ahead of time okay
it's on the animal planet
yeah that's what i'm talking about y'all
know what i'm talking about my man
steve crocodile
hunter crazy dude
dude done lost his mind ain't even been
back yet
forget it i love this guy i cannot
cannot get over this guy man
i'm there every week man
[Music]
right g'day mate
right g'day mates we're going to
crocodile honor i'm steve
g'day hello you know what we're going to
look for real dangerous animals today
you know what the most dangerous animal
is the most dangerous animal of all
the snake
now what i got in my pocket here is a
trouser snake
you watch it he can get you right from
here he's dangerous
go little fella okay we're going to get
inside the truck
with no bloody doors
and look for dangerous animals here we
go come on alright let's go
wait a minute roy remember we gotta be
real quiet
[Applause]
we don't want to scare the animals
it's okay here we go
crikey that was a rare one there
go ahead linda
should be okay
right crikey what linda doesn't realize
is getting closer and closer to her
is a big horny alligator
[Music]
and it's really big too
it's getting closer she can't let's just
watch
out steve
i know it's you but i love you baby
we'll come back later